have you ever been at a game table or
even like a museum where you see like
this diorama of miniatures that's so
detailed that you just wish you could
shrink down and live inside that world
well every time we play d here with our
terrain that's how i feel that's how our
players feel and it's awesome however if
we're making it for a show you as a
viewer you kind of get left out and so
for the past year i've been researching
photo scanning unreal engine virtual
production all tools we're going to need
to make one of our most ambitious shows
ever so come along with us as we attempt
to make the best d d show on the
internet
today is the first photo scan of son of
a dungeon and that's really cool to crap
a lot of pictures
tons of pics we were like hey let's make
a d d show but what's the twist we can
put on a d d show or it's something that
we can bring to it and it turns out that
is putting ourselves into the terrain we
scan the terrain and we make a giant 3d
model that's life size based on that
terrain and then we'll green screen
ourselves into that that way we can have
moving cameras we have a 3d model now
it's like a moving background today
though before we put our live action
bodies into that miniature terrain i'm
going to photo scan the players so we
get actual miniatures of them to play
with on the game board for the games
itself well sam hit me up because you
know we used to play d all the time at
node i'm always down to play d
especially uh with what you guys are
going to do with it it sounds really
cool you look like a member of led
zeppelin i haven't even seen what i look
like here
oh my god
i dig the overall costume my only
complaint is just that
i'm not swole enough i'm swollen the
wrong spot man i don't like having a
beard gut like i'm not kidding i think
we should straight up just cut the abs
out of the suit so i at least have like
the proportions are a little bit more
accurate i like the gut i don't and it's
not your character it's mine oh yeah you
got some rib meat
look at those ripped ribs
so dee was the first person to get
scanned and
his print is completed i'm pretty
impressed with how it turned out so for
reference this is what like a normal
miniature looks like obviously this is
painted they're decent but let me show
you how dee's print turned out check
this out
i still have to cut the supports off of
it but it turned out really really well
once i took those photos i ran them
through reality capture which is our
photo scanning software very fast very
effective added in a little sword a
little crossbow cleaned up the brim of
his hat a bit it resembles d i'm pretty
excited about this
so what is up dude i'm waiting for nat
and jake to get their costume together
so i can scan jake and then after that i
am going to take a peek into the big
shipment from dwarven forge that arrived
this morning i seriously thought we
wouldn't have enough pieces i'm here
because my mom and my dad fell in love
and uh fast forward fast forward
this is essentially what i've done on my
free time building fables so to be able
to now come back and work with sam
someone who's just as passionate in the
genre and the game as me have all the
resources all the knowledge we're
actually partnering with dwarven forge
to build the best maps possible on the
market this is like a dream come true oh
we got sewers
i'm going to sneak in them sewers i've
been using these dwarven forged terrain
tiles for the last 10 years it allows
you to use your imagination for so many
other things that are required for this
game you don't need to imagine what the
room is looking like or the shape of it
now you can focus on the story of the
characters rather than all the
superficial stuff oh
[ __ ] this is the piece i'm talking about
so in the campaign when they drink their
tea this is the device they find where
they're making it pop it pop that tab
pop that tab popping it
this is the kind of game you wish you
could play and that's all what this show
is about let's play the game that
everyone wishes they could play when you
look at this game board it has been
scientifically designed to be the most
optimal playing experience for this
particular layout big dungeon dwelling
maps a dream come true for anyone who
plays or watches d d stuff it's like a
real movie production with one two three
four
five
six cameras if you liked nodesd d you're
gonna love this dmd if you are new to
dungeons and dragons you will not be
disappointed this is going to kick ass i
think this is the most elevated dnd
experience that you can offer but on top
of that going into live action
highlighting the funny the cool the
weird moments that would normally be
hard to communicate i think is going to
elevate this to another level
i'm in cg heaven that's the best way to
put it you know that effect when you see
a diorama where you imagine yourself
shrinking down into that miniature
universe well d d is already that
experience but once it's photo scanned
and processed and then running in unreal
5 it's a whole another version of heaven
it turns out in unreal you can set your
cameras to have a 0.1 aperture which is
perfect for getting this like miniature
effect sometimes the photo scans don't
look so great sometimes the lighting
doesn't look so great because you know
it's a game engine so as long as i keep
it with like a super shallow aperture
like this it's like oh dude that looks
pretty good this is the version that was
in our imagination but now it like
actually looks like that it has lighting
and atmospheric effects i could open
this in cinema 4d but i can't see it
with final lighting and everything in
real time the nanite system helps
because we're dealing with literally
these photo scans of terrain that have
millions of polygons this is like easily
like maybe like 10 million polygons or
something right now i am in my own
imagination creating a small film and
the best part about it is that you'll
actually get to see it
[Music]
coming up on these green screen shoots
so
sam's been behind the computer and doing
all this work and now we have to see if
it's actually going to work as we intend
it to so
time to get a nice uh clean green screen
going it actually looks pretty good
it's nice and nice and once we hit that
curve it's like
it'll be okay for now
the main issue you deal with when trying
to set up a virtual camera like this
you're trying to get them synced up as
closely as possible so that when this
red camera goes capture frame my 3d
position is captured as close as
possible to that exact same moment we
have tools that allow us to
theoretically access that moment in time
but are those tools working i don't know
today we'll find out so
it starts with the lens i'm using this
lens it's a cinema geared lens it opens
up to an f2 which is pretty nice because
we're going to be using super shallow
depth of field for the miniature
backgrounds but most importantly it's
got gearing because eventually i'm going
to be putting a small device that is
going to measure the focus poles that
are being made and translate those to
the virtual camera as well we have an
external monitor here which i eventually
will reroute the computer signal back to
so you can see a fully composited
version of the scene we got a vibe
tracker a vive puck and this is gonna
screw right onto the top of this camera
here
it is going to tell the computer where
we are with the camera all right nico so
let's do this we have a thing on a thing
it's in focus so we're getting the
signal so that's good okay it's working
i
tested it by just simply dragging it
into my scene
there's a live video that's just a plane
of this stuff right now it's a little
dark can you put it at a normal exposure
and keep it there
it's frozen
so i'm wondering if that's
part of this issue that i was talking
about where it sometimes
doesn't work so yeah i hit play and it
doesn't animate and i have to go over
here and manually like reactivate it and
then it starts working
um
all right looks like i'm just going to
go on youtube and watch some tutorials
there's a few things we're still dealing
with one are signals cutting out on our
computer that's important because you're
trying to see the footage on the
computer screen as you're working on
this stuff also there's a little bit of
latency but the camera's cracked right
now you can't see some wiggles sam
there's ever so slightly delay what the
[ __ ] is this i don't get it this is
really unhelpful if it just keeps
stopping because imagine you're trying
to set up a shot and it stops and you
wait so hey double click it again
you go through this process a bunch and
so i hit play and it pops up and it's
not actually streaming it's like this is
a stream this isn't like a video file
there's no i can't click play where's
just like this raw stream where is it i
don't know this is what's been super
frustrating i'm just like show me the
video stream just
by itself this is something that we
probably aren't going to fix today maybe
because there's still everything else to
deal with
hey
are you dealing with jank in your life
maybe you're on a virtual production set
and you can't get any of the equipment
to work well guess what don't worry
because courtesy of today's sponsor
raycon earbuds we're gonna
chop down some of that jank and make
your life a little bit easier with a
premium audio experience because raycon
earbuds are disrupting the electronics
industry for about half the price as the
other competitors but without compromise
sam's out there worrying about how he's
gonna get his video game in front of his
video and how he's gonna mash him
together in a video i don't know what
that even means but i just know that
it's confusing and he's got a lot adobe
in his life so what he needs is a pair
of premium raycon earbuds which
obviously come in a variety of fun
colors and patterns so that he can match
his mood for the day raycon earbuds give
you six hours of play time seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and a more
compact design for a comfortable noise
isolating fit they also have no dangling
stems or wires they took all that and
they
chopped it down raycon has a 45 day free
return policy so whether you're taking
up a new hobby or you want to make your
day-to-day just a little bit less janky
consider getting yourself a pair of
raycon earbuds by clicking the link in
the description below or going to
byraycon.com
corridor crew you'll get 15 off just by
going to byraycon.com
coral that's 15 off your pair of raycon
earbuds make your life less janky get
yourself a pair of raycons and say sam i
appreciate everything you're doing buddy
i don't understand it but good luck
probably get yourself a pair of raycons
because at least those aren't janky
see you later
[Music]
it's a tough pickle kind of day so we're
shooting next week it's thursday right
now so i'm working today and tomorrow
the problem is that i'm just in this
situation where because of the directing
and like all of the technical stuff for
the shoot are both on my shoulders here
it's just like a little too much to
handle as far as like the amount of time
we have before we film no it's still at
an angle
well we're seeing new issues it's at 45
degrees carmichael's in a tilted world
yeah look at me i'm so tilted yeah
just suddenly now it's like this this is
a pretty technical process so we're
trying to align a virtual camera with a
real world camera and big sweeping
motions actually are a huge issue
because our computer's chugging through
it i saw a frame skip but i couldn't
tell what it was could be the wireless
video once again this is also the
situation of me just crossing my fingers
hoping that the technical stuff can get
solved which i'm kind of banging my head
against the wall with right now when you
watch the footage if you look for it you
can see how
some frames don't align and they move at
different speeds from the camera once
keyed
the digital world is
just shitty looking like broken frames
stuttering images it's not too bad
honestly once you put people on stuff
people on it it's super noticeable we're
so close to giving up i feel like i'm on
set on avatar 2 again for a while i was
like oh it's cool i know unreal engine
this is fun and now i'm like this sucks
because
no one else knows how to do anything
like i'm just stuck here alone trying to
figure this out basically everything's
like so freaking close but not ready i
kind of want to just like get throw my
hands up in the air here and just say
we'll shoot when we're ready to shoot i
gotta deal with that right now i'm not
sure what i'm gonna do
so sam
[Music]
are you going to film the meeting
okay the camera assistant's not working
on it's so close basically it's at a
it's at this crossroads here of like
well the camera system is like
close but it's not there and then on top
of that there's constant footage shutter
so there's something happening in the
system where it's like not keeping 30
fps and when it doesn't do that it goes
oh don't capture a frame the footage is
legit unusable this is without gen lock
and despite it looking flawless when
you're filming it it looks like [ __ ]
when you capture the actual frames so
that's without gen lock this is with the
gen lock
the foot is not bad at all with gen lock
on if you guys just chill on the
movement a little bit it's gonna look
great and you know what the slightest
bit of jank
we all know what do we say you know you
know the saying it's the same you're
just gonna open your arms wide
and give it a big hug because this looks
great it's a little bit that nintendo
game show where kids were in the video
game it's just got a little bit of that
but you know what i love that show i
mean if you don't go crazy with your
panning and you just keep it nice and
smooth
it's gonna look great all right get the
jib arm
having the jib on a track right here
with the jib arm so you can do like
panning shots it's nice and smooth
or you know shots going up and down
we have two days to get it and set it up
this is why they're a team
they work well together
they bounce each other out one's got a
problem the other one's got a solution
look at them
i gotta i gotta go
so we got a green screen working we got
lighting got tweak it just a little bit
exposed me correctly and i am in the
darkness we got a whole new jib the
original issue is the drop micro frame
and the smoother the shot the less
noticeable it is our track position is
probably right about here we have a
insane video village monitoring setup
that we're going to have you have three
monitors the third monitor is duplicated
onto the big tv for talent and then
duplicated onto the camera and that
third monitor is going to be the cg
reference that's taking in the green
screen and processing it in real time
and then over here christian is going to
be making sure the cg shots match the
green screen shot and then we'll also be
playing the episodes while shooting so
we can watch each scene that we want to
do
my life is in the [ __ ] lately is that
a toilet it's a poop hole every scout
camp has the forgotten campsite that has
one poop hole that looks exactly like
this and it has all the raccoon
scratches on it and everything
i'm not feeling much right now i'm just
trying to chill and
put everything together while i can
three and a half hours left in my day
here and i need to uh put it as far as i
can but you know
at this point
i'm just gonna jump right in to be
honest with these shots added on top of
full cg shots on top of the table on top
of character art griffin and sound
design and music are we really gonna
complain about what we're putting
together
sponsored not by
day one green screen son of a dungeon
don't you wish that you weren't where
you were at a certain point in time
sometimes
these are rare salts for all those this
is oh they're all labeled what is
something corn dogs corn dogs i honestly
have never had this much anxiety about a
shoot i need to duplicate myself because
i'm gonna be over there on the camera
and i won't be here on the computer i
can't be at both places at once all
right i'm pretty much done check this
out instead of a sling you have these
straps that are built into my costume
with a shield completely locked to it oh
the crowning machine
oh a little bit of warning would be nice
maybe you should be operating the camera
today what you have to do on that end is
so
minimal compared to everything that's
happening here let's go for it all right
we're gonna block this out here this is
the first time we see the characters
it's okay to just stand there and look
cool okay hope this works here we go and
three two
one
action
and cut great work our first usable shot
we did it
[Laughter]
classic batman and robin like the old
show effects you can't like really have
people rappel down a rope without stunt
man they're faking a repel i got a rope
splinter dude look at that i haven't
been able to get that out sometimes
that's how it goes around here blood
sweat and tears you know what i'm saying
so we don't have a lot of green screen
but i have an xbox controller that moves
the whole camera rig so when we have to
run great length i just use the game pad
to make it look like they're running and
they're just going to run in place
stop are we gonna do go go go go
[Laughter]
sorry you started scooby doing and i was
like uh and sorry started moving the
camera and then it looked so shitty
that was really good though listen
sam could just be lying to make all of
us feel better but i do feel this and
i'm going to trust him for now
sweet hey that's not bad that looks
cinematic are you ready are you guys
ready yeah you're ready all right so
we're going we're going
let's go
here now that's why we have us so we can
catch the cameras the
director's throw yeah it's simple you
know matt hey you know you just let it
go
out shots very little technical
difficulties what can i say it's a
well-oiled machine the secret sauce was
honestly it is better for me to just be
here i can watch the shots in real time
when hiccups happen i fix them like
instantly and carmichael's a great
shooter and he's making the shots look
great but the purpose of this system is
to save ourselves a lot of time we're in
a game engine so rendering stuff out is
gonna be insanely fast and not only does
it track the camera but it puts the
camera in the right part of the
environment we're knocking all that
stuff out every time we hit record
actually
i would actually be doing this other
thing and then i'd actually be leading
through here and then
[Music]
okay
that's it wrapped
[Applause]
it's the week after our big green screen
shoot and we just had our first
post-production meeting in preparation
for the meeting i spent five minutes
that's right five minutes putting
together just one shot i think it worked
yeah it's like okay i buy that i did it
i put my boys in the dungeon they're in
there forever they're not coming out at
our current pace even without all this
fun stuff that we're gonna be adding in
there visually i think the story the
characters all that stuff super engaging
it's definitely the best dnd campaign
that i've ever been a part of first
episode is going to drop in early
september and we're going to be
releasing episodes weekly so check it
out on cordialdigital.com